the sheer size surprises everybody and
then the fact that they come right up to
your face they have tiny little eyeballs
and they're very nearsighted so if
they're going to get a look at you
they'll come right up to you to see you
hi I'm Captain Tom with explora
Adventure Center the Crystal River
National Wildlife Refuge is the largest
aggregation of manatees in the world
they come here for our spring Source
they come here to stay warm in the
winter all of our patrons start at the
adventure Dive Center we watch a movie
first Manatee manners the do's and
don'ts of what's going to happen out
here the main goal is not to disturb the
natural behavior of a manatee and we
will hang out with these majestic
creatures and kind of just observe them
when you're in the water with them you
realize how docile they are they may
swim right up to you they may swim right
underneath you if that happens we just
freeze and Float there are a lot of
great places to snorkel in Florida your
family's just got to try the Rainbow
River if that's just north of here in
Dunellen and you tube it you can kayak
it my family loves it thanks for hanging
out with us guys I hope to see you soon
in Crystal River